this is a random minecraft twitch
streamer and if he can be minecraft in
the next hour i will donate him
50 000 oh my god start
a new minecraft game if you beat
it within the next hour i
will donate fifty thousand dollars
i sent a donation let's see what he says
all right there's our donation
look at his face look at the chat the
chat's going nuts
dude what look at him he doesn't even
know what to do i can do that let's do
it right now
i'm shaking right now i feel nervous for
this guy yeah
that's enough money to buy this this
five cars oh can i reset
okay i told him no resetting i don't
even know what this threat is here
the strat is to win to be clear terrible
seed he had such bad luck
four minutes of the hour has already
gone by i just sent another donation
no pressure 50 000 isn't that much money
love
yeah it's it's not right i digging down
oh my god imagine if he just died to
that creeper i know six minutes he is
ten percent of the way done there's our
other donation i hope this doesn't
distract you and lose you
fifty thousand dollars seven seven
i hope so too i hope so too come on chat
let's see the seven
yeah someone said cruel yeah we made it
to the nether he's making pretty good
pace
honestly i just want to play that as
safe as possible for those of you that
don't speedrun minecraft much you get a
bunch of gold you trade it with the
bastion so you can get ender pearls do
you like pancakes we need to know
wait add some sevens what if i just do
this let's see what happens he looks so
annoyed every time i donate
do you like pancakes we need to know 8.8
888 999.
um yeah i love pancakes pancakes are
great oh okay good it's working we're
distracting him
we tweeted out his stream and if you
look he now has over 10
000 people watching oh my god we're
trying to pile a bunch of pressure on
him oh wow
eleven and a half minutes oh he only has
one hour
even more pressure now with all these
people in chat yeah
we did it that's what we wanted yeah
chris come here buddy hey what's up man
for this next donation message chris say
what you want
was it in german why is that in german
there you go
thank you chris i didn't know that was
gonna be my thing whoops
all right we have pearls oh he's got
some pearls yep they're the pearls
can we get more piglets down here
because they don't want to go outside
there because they're all the hoglands
do you think he's gonna win yeah he's
one of the best in the community
i see more pearls down there yes two
stacks wait we just got a dm on twitch
hi mr beast have a good day bye bye
what if he fell yeah he's not going to
fast bridge this one
now he has to find a fortress pretty
desperately bro there it is how is that
in german
well ignore that because snowden just
subscribed it's way more important
why is that in german why not
oh why not why not i didn't know it was
gonna
yeah get out of here hey thanks for
joining us thanks for joining me
you can say whatever you want 10. that's
it you're just gonna say
10. uh plus more plus some more plus
some more there we go there we
go wait why you
typing actually okay 150. it's a very
confusing sentence he's going to be so
good
oh my god someone donated it just goes
[Music]
guess save me 50 grand come on buddy
it can oh my god he didn't even look at
it to watch it die he was certain
what is he trying to do he has to beat
minecraft in under an hour for fifty
thousand dollars
[Music]
did you not even know jayla just walked
in he didn't even know when we were
filming
this is insane how far along is he is he
doing good he's 20 minutes in he just
needs to find a fortress and then get uh
back
look he's doing it all wrong he can't
find the fortress though so if he
doesn't fight a fortress he's screwed
hey my beast put me in the vid you're in
the vid
what he's doing a fire resistance oh
about to say he don't even know what's
over there dude my mouth is also so dry
my man pulled out the cup of water for
today oh here it is
he's probably so confused why we keep
doing this we put 50 grand on the line
he doesn't even respond to our gibberish
that's my stub mr beast doing the most
even on a monday all right where's he
going he pearled there's no fortress
he still hasn't found the fortress
sometimes that's what does it do like he
would have reset by now dang
no there's another bastion oh oh yeah
wish there was a fortress
hey the beast can you buy me call of
duty cold war
that kid was asking you to buy them call
of duty me
he doesn't have that much time dude
there's so many seats better than
disneyland
i know oh my god he has such a bad seed
for this dude he'd probably have better
odds if he just
reset right now and got a better seat
dude he's down bad for a fortress right
now it's nowhere near where he is right
now that's why he has to fast travel
because he just found a bastion
i wouldn't mind if you don't donate
right now i would have no problem with
that i think that's the first time i've
ever heard someone say
don't give me free money okay he has the
soul speed so this is going to be fast
travel
no okay watch this about to be right
here trust me oh
he's bad oh guys three two one we are
now at the halfway point you know what
that means
i gotta take my jacket off cause i'm hot
okay halftime show i did it all right
did he beat the game while i was gone
yeah he just started a new one
the fortress yeah this is this is the
fortress he found it he just found a
fortress okay so now
if he kills some blaze and get some
blades rods he'll have everything he
needs to go to the end holy cow
oh there's blaze right there i think
yeah that's a spawner yeah yeah yeah all
right oh no we got hit by a wither
skeleton all right there's the blaze
get the right oh come on dude you got
three oh no he has to be so careful
i should have played it on easy he's not
playing easy whoops
oh oh oh what if he jumped on that block
oh my god he's two oh double
he's so clutched yeah he might be able
to pull it out how many rods does he
have zero i think i don't think he's got
one since he's at the fortress i think
we should distract him
yes uh uh uh
we add some stuff inside some sevens i
should probably keep track of how much
i'm giving him while he's competing for
50 grand
i might accidentally give him 50 grand
and then another 50 grand later
oh we got one okay you literally only
got one rod off of like seven kills
this is so intense fifty thousand
dollars is on the line
i'm just going out because i need food
wait what was that that ran out of oh
please kill him baby and now what all of
you came for
your favorite part of mr beast content
boating
riveting content sipping water i'm back
what's going on
i don't even know what's going on you
need to throw another one oh
still further how much times do you have
left well you take that and you subtract
it from an hour so how much time does he
have
you know what chris i think we should
give you another donation i'm saying
look out behind you i'm gonna give him a
little prank he's gonna think somebody's
behind him he's got 20 minutes and 30
seconds
oh he's found it and he's got 14 eyes
left all right he found the stronghold
and he's digging down assuming he
doesn't fall in lava
oh why would you say that he's making
pretty good pace you might have jinxed
him
oh wow he found it there's your joke
chris look out behind you i can't afford
to lose
unfair hey this man is focused he's like
i got 19 minutes to make 50 000 he's
like screw you chris
oh yeah get the beds get the beds you
know why he's bringing the beds because
if he gets tired
trust me i'm an expert eighteen and a
half minutes it's gotta be through there
right he can't find it it's another
library right
yep oh no it's a library you can't find
the portal
it's gonna come down to the wires oh
he's getting nervous a zombie dude if
that zombie kills him kind of crit the
zombies just attack it yeah
he's wasting time all right there we go
what if he had fallen in that lava that
my heart stopped he has a little over
17 minutes left to kill the ender dragon
for 50
000 he can do it oh he's got to make it
both he doesn't have any string
he used it all for wool oh no i forgot
the bow oh oh no he meant to make a bow
but here's where he used it earlier yeah
he's got to use the bed straps oh he has
so many beds he's good yeah but he's got
like 17 minutes
what if the dragon just never perched
the next 15 minutes just cost him 15
grand that would be
really bad come on birchberg's first
perks perkins dude this is the slowest
perch i've seen my entire life you got
to feel like
minecraft doesn't want you to win 50
grand at that point is that purchasing
yeah okay he's doing it are you doing it
yeah i mean he's got it
let's make sure he doesn't light on fire
there you go
44 minutes and 58 seconds is lower than
one hour this man just won
fifty thousand dollars what dude this is
unreal right now what is going on you
just won 50 grand we made it guys
we did it the maximum donation is a
thousand euros
no wait it will let me donate the 50
grand well i guess we'll find somebody
else don't worry i'm gonna get him his
money and thank you for watching